so what is Creole and and when I like to
do is to look at same what happens in
the history of of learning French by by
address and by children we saw examples
of that before but what we find there so
this is actually very reverse fact which
is that when when you have people
learning French often so in the case of
the object pronouns they do produce
structures of that sort right in its
have to be in it have to be in a Creole
environment it happens in Marseille
depends in in all kinds of varieties
where you have second language learning
so so delia is that often as you learn
the language you might see particular
order like subject verb object object in
that order is the dominant order often
you take that order in a new applied to
all the elements that that might fit it
right you over terrorized children do
that all the time when children see
things like oh I have one foot and you
have two two foods right saying food and
foods instead of saying foot and feet
it's a mystic that you know almost every
children every child will get to do in
the in the path of learning French
learning English because what do they do
do they real scientist right the after
hypothesis about say cool ok s Multipure
so why should you bother to say feet if
you have to pro well-behaved girl like s
if you say I don't know if you see table
tables if you say pan pans why would you
say food feet you fine I posit it's
right and children do that right so in
the same here if you know that your
language has public order you say you
know Caraballo
hit the ball why would you say when you
have a pronoun why would you put it
before the verb it seems to be a natural
hypothesis if you learn to assume that a
pronoun like a full noun will come after
the affirmance what you see you know and
this is so the contrast is between
standard french where you get the
pronoun before the verb and this is l2 f
ends is a learner's french
and I'd open his french where you get
the pronoun after this right so not to
make a long story short it go ahead big
I don't know maybe just our topic I'm
like why like if it's like the most
natural thing to assume that a the
object follows the variable like how is
house never
how did French ever develop this weird
name in there that's that's a that's a
good question that's exactly it means
that as you learn a language there other
there are other factors in that learning
right so although the learner might have
a natural tendency to do that but since
in the case of French there are norms
yeah books there is TV so eventually the
learner will come will move towards a
different set of patterns you know but
then languages do change and in English
change often days there is a path
towards more general think of examples
so Steven Pinker a very good linguist
was at MIT no mati and he has a whole
book on how the patterns of regular
verbs change in English right things
like go went or Shine's shown so many of
these over time become regular so you go
from shine shown to shine shine well it
hasn't happened yet right but what you
should is that over time there is a
movement of verbs going from being
irregular to being regular and one could
explain that because of the fact that
there's a tendency to make all these
verbs fit the same the same pattern the
regular pattern right very same time
there's also prescriptive norms no
there's a pastiche language there's a
language called tony crock what he
argued that very often changes okay in a
different direction because why because
people use language to show that they're
fancy they are sophisticated so they
will use the more the irregular pattern
to show off exactly who whom cakes right
so how many of you hear people saying
whom in all the wrong places
because right because because whom when
you see whom when you say john and i it
makes sound fancier than John and me but
what you find is that often people we
will see John and I
and I in the wrong place they will say
you know I just had a good talk with
Mary and no no my dad went went to see
Mary and I so but Marian high in that
particular context is not it's not
correctly Mary and me because it is the
object right so why would you see Mary
and I in object position but because
Mary and I sound fancier people would
tend to use it or the home thing earlier
that cases we have to go see whom which
grammatically is not correct but because
it sound fancy so whom should I say is
calling you know I hear that all the
time because they you know whom whom
calls you who told you it should be who
called you right because it's but
because I came to the gram of the
language in that in that particular
environment it's a subject so you don't
expect to get home because whom is whom
it's for who technically you know in
terms of grammar like him is for he or
like her is for she right this is
basically the function of the of the
Ehrmann home it makes it an acquisitive
form but yet people now use whom even
when it's a subject why because it
sounds fancy
itself in fact it's a language that call
it to various a grammar various you get
infected because you want to sound fancy
so let's talk about identity that's one
place where identity might be a role in
language change because by using those
forms you want to project yourself as
being as being superior as being you
know sophisticated know and then you
would use it second in creation Creole
people use often the rounded vowels from
French to show that they know French but
they use the rounded vowels like instead
of e way doesn't belong and they produce
all kinds of weird sentences where you
get all these news where even in French
you have eat because they perceive that
the e is the French is a marker of a
French not Creole and therefore they
want to use it all over the place
you see and it's called a pro correction
you are correcting yourself but as you
ever correct you sound stupid really you
know many know and then there are all
these jokes about it actually because
people are aware that people who use all
these views is really not really know
where to use the e
chef's society and I'm speaking in a
particular way that actually creates all
kinds of weird patterns and eventually
can become part of the language that's
that that's one driving force in
language change it is desired to sound
better than your exact you know people
who vote for Trombley might put four on
them because they believe in some but
because it might mean something for the
identity it's like so language has this
power of also establishing status yeah
the next part that I was going to talk
about how to do with so why why does
language learning by adults have this
effect on say verb order on conjugation
and and the deposit image very very very
quickly which is that you know this is
something which is universal that we
know in many context of language
learning that that adults do have this
effect
santoprene they learn say if you need to
learn say Italian or or any other
languages and have lots of markers on
reverb for conjugation often in the
first stages of learning you you you
don't have these you drop these and it's
a because you're trying to speak a
language and these are to be memorized
and at first you will not memorize it
properly so it seems that it's a general
phenomenon and the point is that so the
key maybe the key paragraph here is this
one that maybe the way to understand
language change and which I in my view
include formation is to consider the
effect of both language learning by
adults and by children and it has the
case then that that's what is it to
drive all kinds of language change not
just what what you see in the case of
Korea formation okay so yeah so so this
is another part of the conclusion just
to recapitulate that basically to those
of you were asking so what's my theory
of close formation I don't need one you
say nothing in one because cross
formation is just
linguist change so whatever linguist
understand about the whaling leaders
change to meet applies to crew of
formation so I have one paper that came
out earlier this year with Eric abou my
my colleague from the B'nai from West
Africa and and the paper is called a new
theory of realization right it's known
instance that it's it should be the
default theory that Creoles like other
languages so therefore you don't need to
have a special theory for them so it
should be the new liabilities that
Creoles don't need a theory whatever
theory applies to French or English
should apply to Creole